1946 voici la première salle de sport
voici ce que l'amérique
bonjour américaine à tomber une salle
avec des appareils qui ressemblait plus
à de la torture cas de la gym suis
aujourd'hui presque 6 millions de
français sont inscrits dans une salle de
sport
le concept a mis du temps à émerger les
premières salles alors appelé centre de
silhouettes arrive dans les années 60 à
paris tout un monde de machines atteinte
ici la femme d'aujourd'hui qui veut
garder ou retrouver la silhouette idéale
mais ce concept de sport en salle ne
prend pas il faudra attendre les années
disco et surtout véronique et davina
pour que la salle de sport devienne
sympa avec les fameux cours collectifs
d'aérobic
j'ai un métier et 10 ans chez obligé dé
trend la dystonie tout le temps chaud ci
et là je suis pas choix d agréables et
sens que je peux te défoncer c'est un
terme qu'on voit pas tellement foyer
mais ça on le fait d'une façon saine et
complète
je ne peux pas vraiment passé
j'ai jamais rien fait avant rennais rien
sauf du vélo habitants boxer tôt surfant
sur cette mode du fitness et des
collants fluo le nombre de salles se
multiplient mais c'est bien dans les
années 2000 que le concept explose 2500
salle de fitness en 2002 en france il y
en a aujourd'hui 4370 la raison de cet
engouement
l'arrivée du concept des salles low cost
avec des machines en libre service et
des professeurs de fitness sur écran
géant en salle de musculation 150
machines
le top de la technologie pour un prix
low cost 25 euros en moyenne par mois
trois fois moins cher qu'une salle de
gym classique c'est ce qui attire la
clientèle
aujourd'hui ces salles de sport pas cher
ont tout englouti sur leur passage
pour preuve les chaînes de fitness les
plus présentes en france ont toutes des
abonnements à partir de 20 euros
de quoi motiver les français ils étaient
1,75 million à courir sur un tapis en
2002 ils sont aujourd'hui 5,96 millions
à avoir un abonnement dans une salle de
sport
[Musique]